everything you see on a spacecraft is
usually designed and built by a
mechanical engineer and I get to do that
my fundamental job is to design and
build hardware that goes out and
explores our universe I build things
that have gone to the surface of Mars
though things that look back on earth
things that have gone out of the ocean
I've built things that have gone into
deep space you get to call your family
and say you know that thing that just
went up there in space and is now on its
way to Mars well yeah I don't that with
one main engine start zero and liftoff
of the Atlas 5 with curiosity she
concludes with a planetary puzzle about
life on Mars but it's an amazing feeling
to have hardware that you've touched and
you've played with and you got to
manipulate in some way on the surface of
another planet
now shopping for Christina
so but do I have a favorite Rover I mean
it's hard not to love the first child
and so our first child is really the
Sojourner Rover which really started our
exploration of Mars with robotic
vehicles and so if you don't have that
first thing you know if it wasn't
Kennedy saying that we're gonna go to
the moon not because it's easy because
it's hard it's the same type of thing
we're not gonna go do roving exploration
on the surface of Mars because it's easy
but we know it's hard people that would
say hey look we're doing all this
exploration in space why aren't we doing
a lot more exploration of Earth I
actually agreed fundamentally with you
I think exploration is the thing that we
should talk about not if we're exploring
earth or Mars or Venus or Jupiter or
Saturn or whatever it is I think it's
exploration it's asking the questions
that need answers and it's that striving
for intellectual knowledge then growth
it's just amazing to think about what's
out there
anywhere on earth that we find liquid
water we find life if there were also
methane around the microbes here on
earth could have survived on Mars